This is Dash & Bash at the National video game arcade, originally
I made it for game [city] here two years ago, and now it's a well permanent partially exhibition. Yes
The game takes place on these four screens
With big green buttons attached to them players get given a card to look for with a picture on it
and then when the game starts
They'll see a bunch of cards flying around the screen
They need to find which screen has their card on it and bash a big button
But as it goes on
It adds in different rules different twists and things and all of these are there to encourage
People to move around the space have to dodge and weave in and out of each other
Maybe even push each other around kind of bash each other out [of] the way
And so very you know I wanted to make a game about
Your playing in a physical space making physical contact and yo everyone is moving a lot through the game
Dash, and bash was a sort of follow-up to a game
I did for big touchscreens called tap happy Sabotage so tap happy Sabotage took place on Earth of
27 Inch Touchscreen and
Instead of you're looking for a button to press to get your card you had to find it on the touch screen
And tap it and then it would add in twist like you had to hold free of your card at the same time or you
had to drag your card out on the way over Baddie bouncing around the screen which also meant that you could grab your
Opponent's cards and just throw them into the body and so the idea with that game is that every different kind of round
Introduced some new twists and with each twist
There was both an opioid there was the rules of how to play which was a different kind of interaction with the screen
but that would also include a way that you could mess up your
Opponent's if you kind of spotted it the thing I kind of learned through doing all these work
Is that it's not about um yo it's not about Complex technology?
You know it's not touch screens that make the game. It's not motion controllers that make the game
I mean these are just big green buttons, but what's change is that creating your own electronics?
Using things like [I] use in Arduino boards to all of this stuff. That makes it easy to set up stuff
That's never been made before but it's all simple it. So you know everyone gets a button and it's what you do with that
That makes it interesting behind the screen says a desktop PC
The buttons are all connected up to an Arduino board
And that's really just taking in input and passing them on to a computer
It's got two graphics cards in it and to HDMI outputs on each graphics card
And that's what's outputting the signal to the screens the Arduino is
The fun bit because that's a bit
You know you can plug that pull that out and plug that into other games and you try making different games with the same hardware
But beyond that is just standard computer kit really the game is built in the unity engine
Which oh, yeah, I found has been very easy to work with very malleable
so yeah, I kind of I
really like unity uh-huh and how long did it take you to make what's the process so the original tap happy Sabotage on the
Big touchscreens was probably about two or three months in development
and then I would start taking it on the road and taking it to trade shows and
games
Festivals watching people play and just continually tweaking
It based on how people
Interacted with it. Which bits click with them which bitch didn't click with them so as anyone, but your cards. It's the last one standing
Continually improving that game bit by bit for about six months before I started work on this one
this version maybe took another month's work to get you into [the] state where it works with the four screens and
Arduino interface, and You've got the buttons and everything and then to that to the game City festival and
During the festival I was considerable continually making tweaks based on
People playing it there and then and when people left the room
I would go in with a uSb key and load in the new version
So I mean it's I think [that's] the reality of game development and particularly with stuff that is for
Use in public spaces is that you don't kind of have a development period Yo you test it out in secret
And then you go, it's ready. Let's launch it
You know you often have to go out with the prototype and try it out on real people as if it's the finished product
Just to see how [it] works, and then you expand it based off of what you learn
It's the sort of evolution is definitely. Yes
And if people are interested in playing these games is this sort of venue the only place you could play again with it um
So dashing bash is only here at the National Videogame arcade
I've also
You know I will often be
At games events and festivals sort of touring around Codecs bash. Which is another game. I'm showing here
I'm working on a project at the moment
to
to do a playable sage show so first version of this show I've been running here at the Game City festival and
You know I want to turn that into something bigger and kind of roll that out
into new venues and
So really it is a case of tracking me down
catching me wherever I am but
hopefully
You know as I take it to more places people will start to say who I want a copy of list for this venue
I'll say okay
I can rustle you up one and you know maybe we'll see a few more of them so watch this space. I guess
We'd like to thank audible.com for sponsoring computer [file] and for you guys
Audible is offering a free book with a 30-day free trial. All you need to do is go up to audible.com
Computer file sign up download a book and start listening. It's that easy now today
I like to recommend seven Eve's by neal Stephenson. I have to confess
I'm a fan of neal's work anyway, and I also have to confess that I'm still halfway through 70s
But it's a fantastic idea. It's gripping it starts with the moon the Earth's moon breaking into pieces and
scientists predict that within certain maybe it's two years that the moon will cause the earth to be
Uninhabitable so they have to work out who's going to survive by leaving the planet or whether going to go underground?
and how many people will leave the planet if so and how just how they'll survive in space, so
Great book check out seven teams by neal Stephenson, and thanks once again to audible for sponsoring computer val. It really does make a difference
the other two canisters are actually butane cylinders which were discarded and
they act kind of like a
gas capacitor the cool accumulators and
They store gas close to where it comes out so that it can come out quickly